Ben Higgins setting the record straight
on romance rumors with another bachelor
contestant
something sad happens in bachelor family
it's kind of silent it's kind of quiet
we don't really talk about it just days
after his split from Lauren Bushnell
been sparked relationship rumors with
Ashley Iook Nettie after the pair was
spotted at a Bryan Adams concert in LA
Ben Higgins and I have our own i heart
radio podcast starting on Tuesday you
will get a little insight there
the former bachelor stopped by on Air
with Ryan Seacrest explaining it's all
business between the two quote Ashley
and I started planning this podcast
months ago way before any of this
separation news happen as for why Ben
and Lauren called it quits he says quote
I think there's a lot of pressure coming
on this show Lauren and I both agreed it
isn't exactly healthy for a foundation
for a relationship it said like probably
light on something that I did struggle
with which was Ben being The Bachelor
and cutting out of The Bachelor and
having to watch him date other women
[Music]
you